trudeau bonjour bonjour bienvenue au
marché jean talon
je vais vous c'est tout près de votre
compte et c'est juste en bordure de mon
compte et donc beaucoup de ces gens là
seraient seraient des concitoyens je
vous envoyer en chine au début
d'entrevue sur une échelle de 1 à 10 la
crise actuelle où la qualifier de
commandes différents éléments d'abord ce
qui nous préoccupe le plus c'est le sort
des deux canadiens qui ont été
emprisonnés en chine
à ce niveau là on est en train de faire
tout ce qu'on fait toujours pourrait
engager de façon diplomatique pour avoir
de l'accès consulaire pour s'assurer que
on est en train de défendre leurs droits
et nos libertés
c'est plus un enlèvement une arrestation
le gouvernement chinois veut vous
envoyer un message et vous parlez est ce
que vous avez paris quelques jours au
président chinois encore on a eu de quoi
qu'est ce qu'on faisait pas prier et
fendirent c'est inacceptable parce que
en politique internationale c'est
toujours mieux de procéder par des
pressions un degré si jamais joui talent
il disait foulée lâché demain une
dizaine on sait quoi ma prochaine
conversation
qu'est ce qu'on fait après ça donc de
commencer avec les ambassadeurs qui se
parlent avec les ministres qui se
parlent pour essayer de régler ce sens
sans mettre plus de pression politique
sur une situation qui ne devrait pas
être politique
eux ils disent ils ont fait des arts et
arrestation illégale selon leur système
dont et vous savez c'est le vrai savez
que c'est un drôle de voir le prouver
avez vous parlé à trois là dessus parce
qu'il vous a pas aidés en disant on
pourrait peut-être se servir de
l'arrestation même wenzhou pour un comme
monnaie d'échangé dans nos disputes
commerciales
encore une fois si les autres pays vont
faire les choix politiques que ils vont
faire nous on va rester dans la règle de
droit
pas seulement parce qu'on est des scouts
mais parce que on en voit reprocher
d'être trop gentil
non non c'est que si les hôtes de fond
des choses qui sont peut-être plus
politique et moins loyaux - règles de
droit ça devient plus important que des
pays qui croit aux systèmes et aux
règles internationales de suivre ses
règlements et de démontrer que nos
nouveaux demeure pays
apple qui ne joue pas de la politique
avec la vie de ses citoyens ok mais les
deux mycal qui sont emprisonnés qui ont
été enlevés par les chinois vont passer
les fêtes en prison peuvent passer des
mois en prison ou dit
pour l'instant il ya les canaux
diplomatiques et rien d'autre à faire on
ne peut pas être plus dur
nous sommes en train de faire ce que
nous faisons quand j'ai des canadiens en
difficulté partout dans le monde c'est à
dire à regarder les processus voire une
justification de pourquoi ils ont en
effet arrêté de fournir des services
consulaires les aider dans leur défense
est si c'est quelque chose qu'on fait
toujours l'arabie saoudite les fameux
blindés vous voulez où vous voulez pas
les vendre à l'arabie saoudite
on a on a hérité d'un contrat mais
milliards de dollars 6 par stephen
harper qui vendait des véhicules blindés
en arabie saoudite
on est maintenant en train de regarder
les permis d'exportation pour voir si on
peut faire quelque chose pour pour le
moins en envoyons ne pas en envoyer
parce que plusieurs actions évidemment
le meurtre d'un journaliste khashoggi ça
était absolument inacceptable qu'ils ont
on exige encore des mers réponse de
l'arabie saoudite mais surtout la crise
au yémen où c'est une crise humanitaire
épouvantable ça prend des actions pour
arrêter cette thèse cette situation est
due au mois d'octobre on va regarder le
permis d'importation là on est rendu au
mois de décembre
vous n'avez pas déjà des débuts de
réponse vous n'avez pas une poignée pour
ne pas envoyer des blindés la mort on
est en train de regarder ça c'est un
contrat qui exige de la confidentialité
malheureusement c'est un contrat de
l'indivisibilité qu'on envoie les mains
on est en train de regarder ce jeu c'est
une réponse vraiment très frustrant pour
moi frustrant pour tout le monde
on est en train de travailler là-dessus
parce qu'on comprend quand j'ai parlé
directement au prince le jjd rêve
badaoui cachot guy yamen c'est des
choses qui préoccupe pas seulement moi
comme vous verrez comme individu et un
gouvernement mais les canadiens aussi ça
regarde mal pour l'arabie le prince
salman vous lui avez parler les yeux
dans les yeux et la brune aux crs est ce
que vous le croyez quand il vous dit que
rien à faire dans marque de cachemire
je pense que l'idée qu'un pays qui est
aussi et les deux qui est aussi
contrôlant que monsieur à sa levée le
prince salman et perdu contrôle de sa
garde rapprochée comme ça ça me paraît
très très invraisemblable lui avait dit
ça j'ai dit on est très préoccupé ça
prend plus de réponses à plus de
comptabilité
non mais on continue et peut-être qu'on
voit quand même envoyé des blindés
c'est là où les gens disent qu'il ya
quelque chose qui cloche
je comprends nous on suit les règles au
canada et je sais c'est frustrant quand
les autres sont pas en train suivi rec
mais nous pour moi c'est pas juste une
question d'être gentil de subir excès de
dire les règles c'est important dans le
monde et quand les gens commencent à ne
pas suivre les règles on fait face à de
vrais problèmes à quel moment on va être
fixée vous allez dire ok on a trouvé une
façon malgré les pénalités on n'en voit
pas où on était jugé je vous promets que
quand on prendra cette décision vous
allez savoir
gilet jaune est ce qu'il ya une morale
pour vous là dedans parce que tu arrivé
en france c'est à dire si on veut lutter
conter changement climatique faut aussi
s'assurer que les citoyens soient
rassurés qu'on va les aider à vivre
c'est les changements dans nos habitudes
malheureusement je pense que c'est cet
aspect là de jeu de dire à qui on est en
train de dame n'est plus la pollution
puis c'est bon pour tout le monde qu'il
faut pour manger comme pour manger ses
bras câline
malgré que j'adore des britanniques
c'est pas nécessairement la bonne chose
à dire
nous ce qu'on a fait notre approche ici
au canada et contre lequel les
conservateurs se bat là c'est de dire
oui on amène une tarification sur le
carbone prix sur la pollution mais on va
aussi aider la famille moyenne 2 avec
plus d'argent que ça va vous coûter en
moyenne pour un pour les nouveaux et
nous la nouvelle hausse qui violent
j'avais raison la taxe sur l'eau en
france jusqu'à 1000 l'huile sur le feu
il ya d'autres choses sur des questions
d'immigration aussi il ya aussi ce
sentiment que les élites et le
gouvernement français dans ce cas là est
déconnecté du peuple je ne craignais pas
que ça vous arrive premier pas de plus
est en contact avec les craintes des
canadiens sur l'immigration sur les
migrants sur le pouvoir d'achat
ma mondialisation aidant des mémés
première entrevue en tant que premier
ministre il ya trois ans j'ai expliqué à
quel point mon plus grand défi
saleilles de rester connecté avec le
monde c'est pour ça que par exemple on
fait encore une série d'assemblées
publiques au au mois de janvier où je me
retrouvais dans des gymnases à travers à
travers le pays pour prendre mes
questions du public et de prendre au
sérieux leurs craintes ou sur
l'immigration par exemple ou est ce que
vous comprenez qu'il ya beaucoup de
québécois beaucoup de canadiens qui ont
des craintes qui sont réelles oui le
décret qui sont dans son énergie et non
non il n'y a pas de problème
parce que je suis entre angie et à
chaque fois les gens qui ont des
craintes
il faut toujours comprendre ses craintes
il ya des gens pour qu ils devoir voir
arriver des immigrants c'est quelque
chose de négatif automatiquement mais
c'est une minorité
la majorité des gens comprennent que
l'immigration nous a bien servis au
canada ou au québec à créer de la
croissance économique ré de
l'opportunité créée une richesse dans
nos vies mais la préoccupation c'est ok
avec ces arrivants d'irrégulier à des
états unis est ce que notre système est
brisée est ce qu on est vulnérable que
notre système est brisé non il est pas
briser chaque personne qui traversent la
frontière quand tu mélanges en 2018
oui c'est plus c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup mais on a les capacités de
faire la vérification de sécurité de
chaque personne
on est en train de les faire passer par
notre système d'immigration et ceux qui
ne sont pas de vrais réfugiés vont être
renvoyés chez eux à la fin du processus
notre système d'immigration qui
fonctionne est encore en train d'être
appliquées de façon rigoureuse et parce
que ça sera un thème la prochaine
campagne électorale monsieur est claire
là dessus et score on accueille trop
d'immigrants on a quelques autres villes
à limoux ce serait trop ce qui n'existe
oui la ligne et elle existe mais c'est
pas une ligne qui existent séparer
d'autres choses la ligne existe là où
plus d'immigrants que ça on n'aura pas
la capacité de bien les intégrer de bien
les permet d'avoir des des emplois de
contribuer en dents de quelques années
ça prend toujours quelques années mais
de pouvoir contribuer à la croissance
économique en général
alors monsieur legault vous le savez en
baisse les seuils est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de lui de lui faciliter la
vie ou de lui compliquer la vie pour ce
qui est de la réunification familiale il
est des des réfugiés ouais j'ai hâte à
ce que nos ministres d'immigration sa
soif pour vraiment parler de ce que ça
veut dire qu'ils commencent à voir parce
que moi quand je me promène partout au
québec
que ce soit à moins de randa que ce soit
à québec que ce soit à à drummondville
ou ailleurs les gens me parlent de leurs
préoccupations par la pénurie de mende
on a une population vieillissante on a
des entreprises à qui doivent refuser
des commandes parce qu'ils ont passé des
deux travailleurs
il ya des gens qui se déplacent aux
aînés séné il a pris la décision inverse
s'ils étaient élus et les québécois dans
les sondages à l'appui
alors vous allez le laisser faire
complètement du compliqué moi ma
responsabilité de veiller à tous les
canadiens y compris les québécois pour
créer des lacs aspérités de la
croissance économique des opportunités
et donc je vais travailler avec lui pour
voir comment est ce qu'on peut serait-il
décès la famille de la réunification
familiale peut-il me baisser on en est
on va discuter de tout cela
comme j'ai dit depuis le début c'est
ouvert de m'asseoir avec lui pour
comprendre exactement ce qu'il veut
faire et comment il veut le faire un tel
problème
il veut résoudre causés au vu de la
croissance économique au québec on veut
créer des opportunités
un bon on est d'accord là dessus alors
les meilleures façons de le faire y
toujours des discussions à avoir on va
travailler de façon réfléchie par le
pipeline une seconde est ce que vous
pourriez un gouvernement fédéral vous
pourriez imaginer pourrait imposer
énergie s pour traverser le québec pour
trouver des débouchés pour le pétrole
albertain ce que vous pourriez imposé
spectre nous certes ce que je dis depuis
longtemps c'est que sans l'approbation
des communautés de la communauté en
général
c'est difficile de on ne peut pas créer
créer des grands projets comme ça et
donc le processus surtout que monsieur
rapport avait mis en place était brisé
les os ne donnait pas confiance aux gens
et donc c'est très difficile d'imaginer
dans l'absence totale d'un projet
maintenant parce qu'il ya plusieurs
lauréats
si on avait dit non on évaluerait on le
ferait passer par des processus si ce
qu'on a vu en colombie britannique
à présent c'est que le gouvernement de
monsieur reviennent et contre l'oléoduc
trans mountain mais on est en train de
travailler avec les communautés il
commence à voir de plus en plus
d'approbation parce que les gens sont
rassurés de notre projet s'il est si le
gouvernement du québec quel qu'il soit
dans le futur dit nous on croit que
c'est pas une bonne idée
le bureau fédéral dans votre avis n'a
pas à imposer un projet ps il n'y a pas
encore de projet mais si on avait un
projet si on avait un projet qui s'y
passe à travers les étapes comme il faut
ici on avait bien consulter tout le
monde
l'on prendrait une décision mais on peut
pas répondre même si le gouvernement
était quand on est dans une situation le
gouvernement de la colombie-britannique
et contre cash en train de faire et on
le fait quand même parce qu'on l'a fait
de la balançoire heures on peut imaginer
un pipeline énergie est même si le
gouvernement du québec est con mais il
n'y a pas de pipeline nerfs
papa roger je n'y a pas de projet
actuellement il ya aucun aucun projet
sur le niveau très projets pilotés de
l'asbl en arbitres la responsabilité
c'est de créer de la croissance
économique pour le pays créent des
emplois à travers le pays est de
m'assurer que l'on joue pas une région
contre l'autre on trouve du sens - des
projets comme ça on les regarde et on va
les évaluer on va parler aux gens on va
regarder leurs préoccupations on va
essayer de répondre à nos préoccupations
mais ya pas de projet pour l'instant
donc on peut penser je trouve dont
l'objectif de 2030 de baisser les gaz à
effet de serre au canada à 30 % du
niveau de 2005
savez vous combien de voitures faudra
enlever du chemin plusieurs 15 millions
système jeu c'est possible si c'était
juste qu'on faisait
mais on est en train de se réaliser il
chante une chanson il faut le faire si
on le fait pas si on ne réussit pas à
elle faire on va avoir plus de feux de
forêts plus d'inondations plus de
sécheresse on est en train d'avoir ça à
des niveaux record on est en train de
perdre un père d'aider des partis
importants de notre notre article
il faut agir et nous allons pouvant le
faire en mettant le prix sur la
pollution
les gens vont agir on va aller voir les
gens mais ce truc de provence on parle
d'environnement de potes c'est ce qu'on
va parler on verra les questions des
gens très bien peuvent voir les gens ce
qu'ils ont à vous demande en cette fin
d'année madame bonjour bonjour ça vient
oui question contenu mise aux questions
c'est un plaisir de ces révoltes mais
qu'est ce que j'ai pu j'ai besoin j'ai
une petite inquiétude pour la décision
monsieur legault à propos de
l'intégration d'immigrants des nouveaux
immigrants ou du regroupement familial
est-ce que vous pensez que il va avoir
un hymne pour les nouveaux arrivages ou
pour les intégrations féminine d'abord
monsieur legault parle du besoin
d'investir mieux pour mieux intégrer ce
qui arrive aux
au québec on avait tout à fait d'accord
à nous devons de s'assurer que les gens
qui arrivent ici peuvent trouver des
emplois à acquérir des compétences
apprendre le français tout ça donc ça
prend un certain investissement chez
toujours ouverts à ça en même temps
j'entends à quel point une pénurie de
main d'oeuvre à travers le québec à
travers le canada ce une bonne chose le
taux de chômage ait atteint son plus bas
depuis 40 ans j'ai des questions et je
continue de poser des questions monsieur
legault pourquoi baisser les seuils
d'immigration quand on a justement
besoin de gens on a des entreprises qui
ferment qui refusent les contrats il me
semble que notre système d'immigration
fonctionne bien il peut toujours et
améliorer mais on devrait continuer à
accepter bien ce que vous attendiez
quelqu'un vous moi j'aimerais sans
apporter ma mère
bon j'ai une pénalité de c'est pour ça
je vous ai écrit une petite led j'espère
que vous allez prendre deux minutes pour
la lire j'avais une bonne journée
prochaine question
moi je pose une question de savoir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé lors de
l'amour propre de la malnutrition égal
dans les succursales de marijuana
oui il ya comme une pénurie
oui il dînera au québec il y en a moins
ailleurs au canada
un des problèmes c'est que le québec a
été lent à développer à ses producteurs
de marijuana ici les producteurs inégaux
et donc la demande a surpris le
gouvernement du québec qui s'attendait
pas à avoir autant nous on essaie d y
aurait plus sympa et ichat une surprise
comme maintenant deux mois c'est une
ligne
oui ça a été une surprise mais tout ce
qu'on sait c'est chaque personne qui se
met en ligne est en train d'essayer
d'acheter de façon légale et autrement
il serait en train de donner de l'argent
aux rovers 1 jaws ou à quelqu'un d'autre
donc c'est un ajustement qui va devoir
se faire ils oublient qu il y avait zéro
marché légal avant le 17 octobre le 18
octobre takuya un marché légal les gens
savaient pas exactement à quoi
s'attendre mais je peux entendre des
pétards dire les producteurs les
entrepreneurs sont en train de s'ajuster
et ça va se régler d'ici et d'ici
quelques mois d'ici un an maxime bonjour
les airs de voix oui bien sûr maintenant
je vais faire mon marché comme
d'habitude j'ai tous mes frères
on aime ce qu'on fait je travaille fort
pour réduire les déchets je fais
tellement d'efforts et je trouve que les
entreprises font aucun effort et ses
pouvoirs publics devraient avoir un rôle
beaucoup plus important par rapport à ça
je suis tout à fait d'accord et c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle on est en
train de mettre un prix sur la pollution
à travers le pays
parce que aussi que le un des problèmes
c'est que y'a trop de pollution parce
que pour lui c'est gratuit donc si on
met un prix sur la pollution les
entreprises
les manufacturiers vont changer leurs
habitudes et vont réduire leurs déchets
si ça coûte rien de sortir trois cadres
aux sacs de vidanges tu vas le faire
gratuitement si on te commença t on vers
un prix tu va choisir de moins en moins
polluer tout va bien ce qui se passe en
france quand tu es donc ça arrive le
coup arrive sur les consommateurs
absolument et c'est pour ça qu'au canada
on est en train d'aider les familles
avec le coût moyen de la tarification du
carbone qu'on a ici au canada on redonne
plus d'argent par année à la famille
moyenne ceux qui ont une grosse maison
ils vont être payés plus d'une famille
moyenne ils vont être on va les aider
dans certains et les gens de la misère
monsieur trudeau pis on les comptera à
réconcilier ce que vous me dit oui et le
fait que vous voulez en même temps
tripler la capacité de traitement de
rennes le pipeline c'est ça les arrange
porsche offre à l'intérieur de notre
plan pour atteindre nos cibles de paris
et un cap absolue sur les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre des sables
bitumineux
donc quel que soit le moyen qu'on va
développer ou vous amener ses produits
le vert les marchés et en cap absolue
sur les émissions et ça ça rentre dans
notre site de paris
donc si on le fait par rail ou si on le
fait par à parler aux dieux pour par
camion
c'est à l'intérieur du cap mais
évidemment transporter par rail
c'est plus dangereux et les plus
polluants que par les eaux turques et en
plus l'oléoduc nous permet d'accéder à
de nouveaux marchés que les états unis
maintenant 90 % 99 % de nos produits
pétroliers de l'alberta sont vendus aux
etats unis
si on avait accès plus à l'asie on
aurait un meilleur rythme annuel
les
le rabais que les américains nous donne
on aurait des milliards de dollars de
plus pour investir dans les nouvelles
technologies dans les programmes de
santé
ça fait partie d'un ensemble qui dit
environnement économique ça doit les
enfants
question si vous avez déjà abordé le
sujet sur le poste mais c'est plus son
lien avec la santé mentale et la
réussite scolaire chez les guides
pourquoi l'avoir légaliser sachant qu'il
peut y avoir un impact important est
trop l'habitude parce que des jeunes de
15 16 ans avait trop facilement accès
aux potes dans notre système existant
qui si on limite sans à 18 ans si on
amène un peu plus de contrôler ces
jeunes là pour avoir plus difficilement
accès aux quais parce qu'on est en train
de traiter au comme l'alcool
ti a pas de marché noir pour l'alcool ou
connaissent quelqu'un de plus vieux pour
aller en acheter mais c'est moins facile
que d'être simplement aller voir le
ghana casier à côté qui vendait du parti
l'accès était trop facile alors on
légalisait pas parce que ces pronostics
mais justement parce que c'est
problématique pour nos jeunes font mieux
contrôler l'accès mais vous pensez pas
qu'il va quand même y avoir un marché
noir qui va continuer justement beaucoup
moins parce qu'un marché noir qui
existeraient seulement pour les jeunes
de 15 16 17 ans avec des conséquences
sur 21 on essaie on essaie de ne pas le
faire pour pour ça c'est pas un marché
qui existerait il n'y a pas de marché
noir pour les jeunes pour acheter de la
bière par exemple ouais mais on va
demander à quelqu'un le plus vieux moins
aimé mais c'est plus difficile que de
pouvoir aller voir un pêcheur qui
n'importe où qui va jamais te demander
une carte d'identité qui n'ont que c'est
une façon de mieux contrôler et de mieux
protéger nos jeunes et leur santé
mentale
super merci beaucoup madame merci tout
le monde moi j'ai trois quatre petites
questions en rafale qu'il est salée pour
les fêtes de fin d'année est-ce que vous
avez déjà comme on dit au québec poignée
lunaire ou es ce que vous avez déjà
d'être devenu totalement et patients
dans la négociation du nouvel aréna
vous avez droit oui bien sûr bien sûr je
suis je suis humain des fois il ya des
moments très difficiles dans toute
négociation mais moi ma job c'est pas de
laisser mes émotions personnelles sortir
ma job c'est de faire tout ce que je
peux pour défendre l'intérêt des
canadiens des citoyens et c'est ce que
j'ai pu faire
donc elle vous a traité de faire après
le g8 par exemple est ce que en privé
vous avez donné les coudes entre dans
une poubelle non c'est pas aussi pas mon
style mais à un niveau humain oui on a
des réactions mais encore une fois
depuis les débuts
ma responsabilité mon choix ça a été je
reste calme je reste positif au travail
avec le président élu par les américains
vous dites on a évité le pire
c'est ça qu'on peut pour résumer aux
gens dans cette négociation le risque
seconde on a pu sécuriser dans un moment
de vrai protectionnisme américain on a
pu sécuriser l'accès à notre marché le
plus important c'est bon que les
travailleurs c'est bon pour les
entrepreneurs s'étaient pas garantis
qu'on allait pouvoir garder une vertu
des parts de marché par dr laitiers
d'ailleurs j'allais les compare ces cas
là on est en train de travailler vécu
pour pour figurer exactement c'est quoi
la façon d aider en faisant poser la
question mais une fois je vous la pose
netflix prenons l'exemple de nietzsche
ou à quand une obligation pour qu'ils
perçoivent la taxe comme un groupe
pareil comme illico comme tou tv
je comprends la question mais c'est pas
une caisse du veltins c'est pas une
question sur un un un produit en
particulier on a toute une économie en
transformation des produits digitaux
assez nouveau il faut figurer des façons
d'appliquer à deux de façon large ce
qu'on est en train de faire mais on est
en train d'avoir des réflexions dessus
pour l'instant on va pas percevoir une
nouvelle taxe sur les canadiens sur
internet
c'est une taxe qui existe c'est la tps
et on s'est juste exiger d'eux comme la
france comme l'allemagne les données
gens pensent que netflix est pas en
train de payer la part des potes c'est
pas eux qui payent c'est une taxe sur
les consommateurs et moi j'ai entendu
des canadiens les québécois à me dire
ils payent déjà assez ou même trop pour
l'avenir ne trouveraient pas leur
ajouter des vrais pourquoi ça sur fire
pour le fait pas c'est ça qu'on
comprendre on est en train de regarder
une façon de le faire dans l'ensemble à
l'échelle mondiale parce que c'est pas
juste un pays tous les pays font face à
ces discussions et à ce défi on est en
train de le faire de façon rigoureuse
on n'est pas contre l'idée que quand on
paie des taxes sur tout mais la façon de
le faire est important donc je vois que
ses passes et pau mur encore nous on a
aussi cassé mais on est dans un nouveau
monde par rapport à ça c'est pour ça
qu'on est en train de travailler pour
voir des solutions de trudeau au revoir
leur famille merci merci tout le monde
au revoir c'est tout le monde